primer día de cierta normalidad en los
centros de salud de Madrid como este que
tengo a mis espaldas hoy a las 8 de la
mañana se desconvocaba la huelga de
médicos de atención primaria y pediatras
que se mantuvo durante 115 días el
acuerdo firmado entre los responsables
de sanidad de la comunidad de Madrid y
el comité de huelga de Los profesionales
de la salud establece entre otras
medidas un tope al máximo de pacientes
diarios 34 paramédicos y 24 para
pediatras que tendrán Entre 10 y 15
minutos para cada uno de sus pacientes
una rebaja significativa ya que
actualmente las agendas a veces
superaban los 60 pacientes al día por
cada médico además habrá un incremento
salarial de 450 euros mensuales para
todos y bonos de hasta 500 euros
adicionales al mes para quienes cubran
el turno de tarde precisamente los bajos
salarios era una de las principales
quejas entre los sanitarios en Madrid
región de la que el 70% de los médicos
residentes formándose para en atención
primaria querían marcharse por las malas
condiciones laborales Y es que Madrid no
dedica ni el 11% de su presupuesto en
sanidad a la atención primaria cuando la
media nacional está en un 15% una cifra
Por cierto muy por debajo de lo
recomendado por la Organización Mundial
de la Salud que está en un 25% para los
médicos que aseguran estar moderadamente
contentos con este acuerdo este es solo
el primer paso para frenar así la
hemorragia de la sanidad pública
madrileña